so now I want to play fate of the
furious friend you've been with the
franchise since the beginning you know
each other really well I'm going to ask
you some questions about your path name
okay which cast member is a picky of
cedar I would say then cuz he doesn't
like cheese there are certain things you
can't put it on a plate for him and you
know I would say that would make him
picky right
probably missile hell so because I'm not
a second ticket either vegetarian or
vegan so she just is online you can't
eat that it's got hormones and I mean
she's very extreme with everything that
had to do with food yeah okay guys
alright I think the room is always
cooking least picking Atari he will eat
whatever you've got the biggest Munchie
problem on the planet I mean really I
cannot live without
munchies almost sighs food lover you
know my bank account has changed and my
taste course is what it is which cast
member is the biggest prankster I would
say Terry it was actually Paul Walker
and probably me I thought was a sneaky
smile all actually put on like a little
hood and some fake muscles and pretended
to be VIN and you know of course that
was something that was cooked up by by
Tyrese and Paul's which cast member is
the set therapist the one that everybody
goes to prevent sessions for advice
before to go through uh Ben yeah he's
the set their co-star would be me oh
really I'm also really good at keeping
secrets
it depends what kind of therapy they
want who do they come to if they need
something to get done it's always good
to know good to know not even close
who does the best Dom Toretto impression
cuz I've heard a few today I bet you
have I bring you a favorite pastime of
all the actors at Universal how do we do
it this down trip there's people that
people that aren't even in the thousand
years my sons and
does be bus Dondre I don't conference I
got family this is adorable the best dog
feretto impression goes retirees make
sure you ask him to do it I'm not good
at impressing the thyreus will kill it
for you then diesel sad take one I don't
know exactly what I'm supposed to do but
I'm not going to let anything compromise
my family everything to enjoy doing it
oh really wrong for different is yeah I
think I did notice he does have your lap
down oh I love that
[Music]